we're going to get to beef because beef
is so relatable and I know you're
probably like wait it's relatable what's
wrong with you
um and that's what you're thinking now
too if you've watched it but let's talk
about it because it's your new Netflix
series it's called beef
tell everybody what it's about like kind
of in a synopsis okay so beef is about
these two strangers it's me and Steven
young so good and we get into a road
rage incident and then we become
obsessed with each other and our lives
start to unravel and
um gosh I can't say enough about what a
great guy he is I think most people
probably know him from The Walking Dead
He's Glenn
yeah and it's cool because in this show
he gets to show a lot of his like
comedic chops he's such a funny person
and hilarious but I think what's great
about both of you is you Encompass like
every emotional state like there's
sadness there's anger and like even
having some even having that person to
just take it out all on like you know
I'm saying it's obviously not that
person it's everything else going on
around it but I think a lot of people
relate to that do you relate to the
character at all I do relate to the
character and I think just like
her like her having this not feeling she
has a space to be angry or to be ugly I
think a lot of women yeah relate to that
when he came at you about that gratitude
Journal oh yeah it's like pick your
moment and like it's like and so
gratitude Journal is great that's great
but like when someone doesn't want to
hear about it is when they're drowning
yes I have like my husband in the show
is a super positive guy and he's so
positive and my character tries to like
uh really vent to him and he kind of
shuts it down yeah and this very like
positive way but it's still shut down
yeah you know and so
yeah so I think everyone's had that
where you're like oh no no no I really
it took forever for me to even voice
this exactly and now I'm voicing it and
you just shut it down that's super fun
yeah and it's also like that unleashing
um and like venting and is also a form
of intimacy and so when he shuts her
down it's like oh you don't want to go
there with me yeah you know like this is
a very for us because it's essentially
and yet guys opening up yeah and yet
guys in it is like oh I love you I want
the best friend it's like well then be a
part of this with me right it's it's
really interesting the relationships in
it the just anger in it of like of just
how life happens and it's not perfect
and and carrying the weight of
everything oh my God that one point and
your mother-in-law oh my oh yeah
she does such a great job of being
unlikable
I love it it's such a great show if you
haven't seen it guys
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
guys I'm going